homophobia what a weird thing huh any
homophobes here yeah like I did some
shows in Boston recently I was talking
to this guy after the show I told him
about a friend of mine who's gay this
guy goes you have a gay friend I
wouldn't even shake a gay man's hand I
was like Jesus Christ why not he goes
you know how many dicks are on that
hand I was like well you shook my hand
you okay with my
dick cuz 's a lot of interaction between
the two all right yeah I don't know I
think homophobia can actually be kind of
dangerous you know a friend of mine he's
kind of a tough guy he went skydiving
recently he's like yeah I'm not
strapping some guy to my back that's
super gay now he's
dead